[Musique]
c'est un terrible fait divers qui était
révélé il y a quelques heures toujours
beaucoup de zones d'ombres autour de la
mort de Valentin cette étudiant tué dans
son appartement
décident de contacter les autorités à
leur arrivée dans son appartement du 16e
arrondissement de Paris les pompiers et
les enquêteurs découvrent le jeune homme
dans une mare de sang le jeune homme
aurait été poignardé à l'arme blanche
dans son appartement qui est situé au
rez-de-chaussée en histoire à
l'Université ses voisins toujours sous
le choc le décrivent comme un jeune
homme gentil et sans problème c'était un
passionné de politique pendant son temps
libre il assistait aux émissions
télévisées il adorait en parler entre
incompréhension choc et hommage Valentin
21 ans et sans histoire sauvagement
poignardé chez lui que s'est-il passé
[Musique]
merci Michel Marie d'être avec nous et
merci Alexis soyez proche de Valentin et
Associés Michel déjà
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a pas
compris en fait et c'est vrai que
comment savoir d'autres petites pistes
qui commencent à surgir
ça commence samedi 4 mars dans
l'après-midi des amis de Valentin des
copains de fac
qui avait fait la fête avec lui le
mercredi précédent n'arrivait pas à le
joindre depuis deux jours donc ils ont
appelé le téléphone répond pas etc et
donc il décide puisqu'il ne répondait
pas au téléphone de se rendre à son
domicile donc dans le 16e arrondissement
juste à côté de l'avenue Mozart
c'est rue de la Cure très exactement et
lorsqu'ils arrivent devant la porte il
louait une petite chambre de bonne et
les chambres dans un dans un immeuble
assez récent des années 80
90 peut-être moderne en tout cas les
chambres de bonnes sont au
rez-de-chaussée d'accord et donc il
avait loué cette enfin ses parents lui
louait cette chambre pour qu'il fasse
ses études il était étudiant en
troisième année de licence d'histoire à
Paris 8 à Saint-Denis et lorsque les
copains arrivent devant la porte ils
trouvent des traces de sang
sur la poignée et sur le sur la porte et
évidemment ils sont vous l'imaginez plus
qu'un inquiet ils appellent les pompiers
les pompiers arrivent sur place
trouve une un double des clés ouvre la
porte et trouve derrière la porte le
corps de de Valentin qui avait 21 ans il
a été tué à coup de couteau très
probablement
la police évidemment arrive sur place et
constatation la brigade criminelle et
saisie et l'enquête démarre mais ça
c'était ce week-end voilà le résumé de
il y a eu des signes d'infraction pardon
il y a eu des signes d'infraction au
niveau de la diffraction les fractions
non il y a pas de signe des fractions
alors quand il y a pas des fractions
on sait que il y a deux digicode il faut
soit avoir le code soit avoir un pass
vigip
donc c'est très compliqué d'accéder dans
à l'intérieur de l'immeuble et quand en
plus il y a pas des fractions ça veut
dire que soit il a ouvert à son ou ses
meurtriers on sait pas combien ils
étaient
soit ils étaient ensemble et c'est une
dispute comment savoir des éléments que
je vais vous donner un son d'une pièce
ici si vous avez les mêmes éléments que
moi ou pas sur l'enquête en cours Alexis
vous êtes un proche de Valentin vous
êtes son associé vous avez appris ce
drame comment vous j'ai appris ça samedi
soir
une amie de la faculté de Valentin nous
a contacté sur les réseaux sociaux de
csaq et immédiatement j'ai été mis au
courant
je l'ai appelé et
un petit peu sous le choc elle m'a elle
m'a évoqué le la disparition de Valentin
à ce moment là on ne sait pas trop
comment réagir et
les premiers mots
vont avant tout à sa famille et à ses
proches
ces dernières semaines est-ce que vous
avez senti un changement chez Valentin
ce qui avait de nouvelles fréquentations
pas du tout
écoutez je suis avant tout là j'ai envie
de dire pour parler de ce qui faisait
dans sa vie on le voyait souvent des
passions
je le voyais énormément dans un cadre
professionnel dans le cadre du journal
mais je n'ai je n'ai pas d'éléments sur
sur sa vie personnelle privée alors il
voulait absolument travailler dans les
médias c'était son rêve qui n'éjouit
venait souvent nous voir ici Valentin
Moktar le connaît le connaît très bien
et c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un voilà
que nous on connaissait et c'est
vraiment qui était sans problème c'est
incroyable donc c'est pour ça quand on a
appris
le drame Michel on s'est dit on comprend
pas c'est vraiment quelqu'un de sans
problème Gilles aucune histoire
apparemment il aimait tellement la la
politique et puis vos émissions qu'il
était dans le face à Baba Olivier Véran
il était dans le public c'était un
passionné il voulait se destiner à ça
alors sans problème aujourd'hui il y a
juste visiblement il y a trois ans à peu
près des traces d'un raquette quand il
arrive à Paris et d'un vol donc alors
c'est quoi est-ce que c'est lié il y a
eu un raquette au moment où il arrive à
Paris en 2019 venant de Brive il aurait
été racketté par des gens peut-être lié
déjà cette générosité qu'il habitait
parce qu'il recevait des gens
difficultés en permanence pour les aider
donc on sait pas encore si c'est lié
mais il y a cet élément avec à l'époque
un vol et aujourd'hui les enquêteurs ne
font pas le lien directement mais ils
vont remonter dans son passé pour voir
s'il y aurait
quel compte client entre ce raquette et
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui je sais
pas si Michel a plus d'éléments sur le
raquette parce que ça tombe ça vient de
tomber cette information en fait une
information je l'avais mais c'est ça me
semble un peu vieux c'est c'est pas de
la grande délinquance c'est petit vol
c'est un étudiant à l'époque il y a
trois ans il avait il avait 18 ans donc
il devait pas détenir des des fortunes
ou des des des valeurs avec lui donc je
sais pas
c'est une piste l'enquête aussi qu'on
aurait est-ce qu'il était sur des sites
de rencontres ou pas du tout ça j'ai pas
cette information d'accord j'ai pas
cette information
effectivement on s'est posé la question
il y a en gros en l'état puisqu'il y a
pas des fractions et ca priori le le ou
les tueurs sont rentrés à l'intérieur de
son de sa petite chambre
soit c'est un familier soit c'est
quelqu'un qui était qui l'avait rejoint
on sait qu'il était sorti ce soir là
qu'il est rentré
ses copains ont un sms ou plutôt un
message vocal à 1h30 du matin où il leur
dit qu'il est bien arrivé qu'il est bien
rentré chez lui donc la
mort survient un petit peu plus tard
dans dans la nuit est-ce que quelqu'un
l'a rejoint est-ce qu'il hébergeait
quelqu'un est-ce que comme
on le disait tout à l'heure il avait
l'habitude de d'aider les gens en
difficulté est-ce qu'il a pas hébergé
quelqu'un parce qu'apparemment ça a été
extrêmement violent je crois qu'il en
avait arraché la porte de la de la
douche on va retrouver sur le lit
sans rentrer dans les détails c'était
une scène de crime assez violente
donc voilà et après il est c'est
vraiment très tôt pour pour tirer des
conclusions
c'est vraiment il y avait pas de bien
sûr
pour parler de lui c'était Valentin
c'était une personne d'une générosité
incroyable une curiosité d'une
intelligence et on vous l'avez dit qu'il
voulait travailler dans les médias
il avait une passion pour ça quand il a
intégré la société qui travaille pour
TPMP il était vraiment dans un cadre
qu'il aimait et ça se ressentait encore
plus de notre côté parce qu'il avait en
permanence des projets qui voulaient
apporter Valentin c'était ça c'était ce
visage d'une jeunesse qui qui souhaite
aller au bout de ses rêves qui
souhaitent faire de sa passion son
métier et qui donnera tout pour pour le
réaliser et je pense que dans l'hommage
qu'on peut lui rendre c'est avant tout
ça c'est de se dire que
cet étudiant et amis
reflète une
chose d'inspiration pour beaucoup
d'étudiants ça sa famille elle a réagi
c'est vrai que quand on apprend comme ça
la mort un proche vraiment on s'y
attendait pas du tout
en plus aussi sauvagement
entre la personne et la violence
exactement ça générosité les restos du
cœur des associations l'aide à des gens
difficultés et la violence terrible de
la scène trois coups de couteau du sang
partout une pièce totalement dévastée
alors on sait pas encore si il y a eu
vol ou pas mais voilà la scène de
meurtre
d'une violence terrible et il y a il y a
un contraste qui fait que les enquêteurs
pour le moment se demandent exactement
ce qui s'est passé il me semble que il y
a des empreintes quand même déjà qui ont
été retrouvés voilà qui pourront leur
permettre d'avancer et je crois aussi
que le couteau a été retrouvé sans doute
peut-être l'arme du crime ce qui va
permettre aux enquêteurs d'avoir une
vision un peu plus claire de la scène du
crime et ce qui s'est passé dans cette
dans ce drame